you
you
welcome everybody we've got something a
little different today Donald Trump's
new press secretary Kayleigh McKenna
knee is going to be holding her first
White House press briefing this is
notable for a whole bunch of different
reasons number one you might remember
that Donald Trump's last press secretary
Stephanie Grisham didn't hold a single
press briefing not a single press
briefing during her entire tenure
believed to be at least partially
because she simply couldn't handle it so
the fact that Kayleigh McKenna knee will
be holding one at all implies at least
that the Trump administration believes
that Kayleigh McKenna knee can handle it
now it'll also be interesting because
Kayleigh McKenna knee for if you just
look at the press secretary official
Twitter account has been disseminating
violent disinformation about everything
you can imagine since she was a selected
I guess it's been a couple of weeks now
or something like that so it will be
interesting to see how she does now a
bunch of people were tweeting me earlier
today saying David obviously she is
going to get absolutely crushed and
destroyed today by the White House press
corps I am not so sure I mean listen you
you will they she knows what to expect
and she's not she's not incapable of
remembering a series of talking points
so she's probably you know when when she
gets asked if we have enough testing why
don't we even have enough tests for 100
senators to all get tested when they
come back to DC she'll have an answer
for that
she'll be asked you know maybe why the
u.s. is forty first in testing globally
per capita and she'll come back and
she'll do something similar to what
Trump does which is just say listen
we've done more tests than anybody else
and it's very local I what I don't have
to come up with it the point is I'm sure
she will show up prepared so I'm not
making any predictions as to whether
this will be a historic fiasco that goes
down as her first and last press
briefing or if she will be able to
control the press corps I don't know but
I expect it to be interesting
nonetheless and I will
we'll be standing by for that less than
20 minutes hopefully she is more
respectful of the press course time than
is Donald Trump who often shows up 15 20
30 even 75 minutes late to his own press
briefing so that will be happening
roughly at the top of the hour you may
notice that I have two band-aids on my
left hand today and a very very ugly
thing happened today which I will tell
you about just so people don't worry
more than would be appropriate and you
should be worried I was as I do every
two months replacing my Brita water
filter and when I do that I like to
totally take apart the Brita and clean
it and you've got like the clear outer
part and then you have the plastic piece
that fits in which is where the filter
goes I'd take it all apart and I wash
the entire thing that white piece was
the filter basket we could call it was
very stubborn I took the back of a spoon
to try to pry it in and be able to
separate it and due to the build-up of
pressure it was such an alpha male
moment where I almost single-handedly
bent a spoon with just my right hand it
was crazy
the force became so great that it
slipped and gouged out pieces of two
fingers there was a piece of skin on the
counter in front of me my girlfriend
almost burned the entire house down
before getting me abandoned a couple of
band-aids and it was a it was a crazy
moment I mean it was just my
testosterone was overflowing to such a
degree that I I destroyed endless pieces
of elements of the kitchen and
unfortunately took a piece out of my
skin so that's what's going on and you
know it's this is not a good time to
have to go get stitches so I'm hoping
that because there's really nothing to
stitch it's just a piece was taken out
I'm hoping that soon the bleeding stops
and that I won't need any elements of
medical applied to my fingers so that's
what's going on painful but a
demonstration of my manhood as people
are pointing out in the twitch chat
absolutely okay let's see Chris K says
we're not going to
make it through this propaganda via
YouTube super chat Rob Miller sends some
kind of crying emoji and Charlie says
not to make light of your injury but at
first I thought that was from smashing
the like button too hard yeah that that
I have injured my hands smashing the
like button on YouTube but usually it's
more of a dull injury this was very very
much acute and you know smashing the
like button too hard is likely to get
you a bruise this was just a piece of
skin being totally totally gouged out so
an ugly situation but we've survived so
far I did pour some hydrogen peroxide on
it III do have isopropyl alcohol which I
could have used but I'm saving that in
case I need to inject it to cure
coronavirus so I wanted to save that and
instead I used hydrogen peroxide we are
standing by welcome on Twitter twitch
YouTube and Facebook for a top of the
hour briefing from Donald Trump's new
propaganda press secretary Kaley McKenna
nee she I presume she will come prepared
we don't know but we will very very soon
find out let's look at the latest
coronavirus numbers the global
coronavirus case toll currently three
point three six million cases two
hundred and thirty seven thousand deaths
in the United States the official
numbers have Crested 1.1 million we are
just a hair shy of 65 thousand deaths
the if to give you real quick the last
24 hours of news on coronavirus two
vaccines may be ready for emergency use
by September October one trial of a
thousand patients with ROM des aveer
seems to shorten the disease by 30
percent another trial with 250 or so
people shows no benefit to room des
aveer Kaylee McKenna D by the way
tweeting that Donald Trump has been
talking about room des aveer since
mid-march again propaganda pretending
like he wasn't only talking about
hydroxychloroquine for six weeks and the
latest testing numbers we still are not
anywhere near where we need to be we
tested only two hundred and six thousand
people yesterday only two
31,000 the day before these are very
similar numbers to what we had at the
beginning of April I mean okay it in
April the average average was probably
more about 120 now we're averaging about
200 but it's been an entire month we
need to be at 500,000 a day we need to
be at a million a day two million a day
lastly there have been armed protesters
let me find this video armed protesters
at the Michigan State Capitol armed
meaning with long guns and short guns
you can see here this is a gentleman
expressing his perspective it looks like
he's got the f-bomb on the back of his
shirt and he has a weapon what would
this have been like if all of the
protesters were black I'm just asking
the question I I don't want to presume
the answer but as you can see a lot of
folks responding very strongly to my
question police apparently calmly just
standing there as armed protesters
scream at them as they demand the state
be opened would this have been handled
in exactly the same way were these you
know of Muslims wearing traditional
Muslim garb or a black folks or whatever
I don't know the answer I don't know the
answer but I'm certainly interested in
hearing your thoughts about that we are
now standing by for live video Kaylee
McKenna knees first press briefing
expected today let me say thank you to
Ulta kemper who is new member number one
at join pakman.com very much appreciate
that
super chats can own a hold on before I
get to super chats let me do some twitch
thank-yous Heather GW has subscribed
with twitch prime thanks Heather
and also taya net has subscribed with
twitch prime for the fourth month
excellent very good all right super
chats coming in giant squid says there
is no spoon David okay Holly asks do you
love black people
I do I do love black people jay-ar says
power isn't airing human minds to pieces
and putting them together again in new
shapes of your own choosing George
Orwell that is indeed what Kayleigh
McKenna knee is going to try to do today
to try to make the case that Donald
Trump is doing a good job and that is a
difficult case to make apparently not
that difficult to make it to Trump it's
okay
mattias Germany sends a super chat David
you will be better with hydroxy
chloroquine I hope not to need any
hydroxychloroquine Corey Keene says
anybody with right-leaning views that
you respect
not a single person my friend no I'm
kidding look I don't want to give lists
but sure yeah I mean there's
right-wingers who you know there's
fiscally conservative people who are
perfectly reasonable people but but I
just disagree with them
Adrian benningfield says David are you
going to cover the work strikes live
maybe we will see what the day brings
Brian Cole D hey Brian he says we aren't
even close to opening the state of
Massachusetts yeah so Charlie Baker the
Republican governor here has put
together a committee set to figure out
what is it that we can do on May 18th
right now Massachusetts is closed until
May 18th if I had to BET right now did
anybody hear that that was a weird noise
hopefully hopefully that the house stays
together I my prediction is that they're
going to do something on May 18th
maybe you open restaurants with outdoor
seating with diminished capacity I I
think they're going to have to do
something because my instinct is that
May 18th is really going to be the limit
for a lot of people we'll see what the
numbers are by then we will see what the
numbers are by the way then I was
reviewing the numbers in Massachusetts
average age of death in Massachusetts
from coronavirus is 82 and 58% of the
deaths have been in long term care and
nursing homes tragic and 98.5 percent of
the deaths have been folks with
comorbidities that's those are the
latest numbers that I have read so far
okay still standing by for live video
here Kate clicks as regarding protesters
you
know the answer David hey I'm just
asking questions my friends I'm just
asking questions I don't I don't you all
have more answers than than I do
okay also want to thank overrun twitch
dub fo Tech who has subscribed with
twitch prime remember if you have Amazon
Prime at which Prime subscription is
free to you free to you but we get paid
which is extremely exciting
JAF 94 says here in Oklahoma I'm seeing
maskless people leave packed restaurants
help that's not good that's not good and
I wish I could help you reading a very
interesting book about Oklahoma right
now killings the killer killers of the
flower moon it's about the murders of
Osage folks in the 1920s in Oklahoma
which ultimately led to the sort of
formalization of the FBI excellent book
by David gran and highly recommended
highly highly recommended if you're just
joining us this is something a little
different we this is not a Trump press
briefing this is Trump's new press
secretary Kaley McKenna nee who we are
expecting at the top of the hour this is
her first press briefing Trump's last
press secretary Stephanie Grisham did
exactly 0.0 press briefing that's zero
none Kaylee McKenna knee a couple of
weeks and now expecting her first one
today and we will see how it goes I'm
curious to see whether she can handle it
and we will see that the degree of
nastiness of the questions kate click
has subscribed with twitch prime & n
Patrick Smith has also subscribed with
twitch prime as a hype train gets
rolling out of the station over on
Twitch angel Mercado has subscribed at
the SOI boy level on YouTube
Michael Blanco says Trump says storming
a government building with assault
rifles is fine but God forbid they take
a knee on a football field to protest
the actual oppression yeah I mean listen
it at these these people are disgusting
they're just sick sick people and the
double standards are stunning the
immorality of this administration is
stunning the
competence of this administration is
stunning and all we can do is get him
out in November vote them out in
November they would be removed in
January that that's the tool we have at
our disposal right now he's not going to
be impeached and oh by the way yeah I
got some emails about is Trump going to
pardon Flynn
you know Trump's pardon power is
absolute is he gonna pardon Roger stone
interestingly enough governors have been
impeached I learned this in the book I'm
reading about about Oklahoma you
governors have been impeached for misuse
of their pardon power there's no rule
that says a president can't be impeached
for misusing pardon power obviously
Republicans will never impeach Trump no
matter what he does even if he to quote
him were to shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue but this idea of the pardon power
is absolute well it's absolute but you
can be impeached for misusing it thanks
to ELISA Morin ELISA is new member
number two today at join pakman.com okay
let's see here Matias Germany says
please try hydroxy on your skin what's
to lose our home says have you read
Camus z-- the plague please do I
actually have not I actually have not
Alex Jones says thoughts on Tara Reid's
rape accusations of Biden already have
three clips talking about that on my
youtube channel I have three more coming
out this weekend you know this is not
the Tara Reid show Donald Trump has 46
sexual assault allegations against him
including ones by a thirteen-year-old
girl I can't make my entire show about
allegations against people in power of
sexual assault maybe if people are
looking for a show just about
allegations of sexual assault then
somebody should create one but we we
have many other things that we also need
to talk about here so by Monday I will
have six clips related to Tara Reid on
my youtube channel and that seems like a
reasonable number to me at this point in
time if folks disagree if the numbers
should be 50 then let me know thanks
also to David now for subscribing on my
youtube channel at the SOI boy level
so what are
folks expecting to see today in this
first press briefing for Caylee McKenna
knee let me know if you're watching on
YouTube you can send a super chat that's
what those messages are in the lower
left of the screen if you are on Twitch
you can send a message with your twitch
subscription it'll show up in that
vertical blue box above me and very
interested to hear whether people expect
an implosion whether they think she is
going to do very very well you know for
me I don't know much about Christianity
in the sense that I'm not a Christian
and I'm just not an expert in
Christianity but I thought there was
something in Christianity about telling
the truth and not being an incipient
liar Cayley McKenna knee very proudly
where is her Christian cross hanging
from from a necklace and lies
uncontrollably I mean it's a it's like a
dishonesty diarrhea constantly emanating
from her would Jesus appreciate that my
guess is if she were confronted with it
and and really forced to answer she
would say that the ends justify the
means and the godly thing is to support
Donald Trump if you've got to say a few
lies in the middle of it the ends
justify the means that's my guess as to
how she would defend her lying and her
Christianity in practice you probably
just like wouldn't answer at all okay
looks like video is getting going here
okay we are standing by oh this is go it
looks like it is the full press corps
and this could be very very very
interesting I'm glad you're here with me
we're gonna be taking it all in together
let's see here other super chats coming
in love inspired seven says this woman
is going to embarrass herself during the
press briefing I can feel it and I can't
wait that is one perspective for sure
Austan egg Eamon's has ever done
psychedelics if so tell your experience
I have not also thoughts on legalizing
them for medication or recreational use
yet it seems like there's a lot of
promise to micro dose micro dosing in
the right setting and I've interviewed
Rick Doblin on my program who works in
that field and I have no problem with it
whatsoever beamer dave has subscribed
twitch Prime Sammy's Tech has subscribed
with twitch Prime optics 71/4 is a new
subscriber with twitch Prime and toker
smoker is a new twitch prime subscriber
also white stir 888 very much
appreciated
Rennes holder 57 says she's going to
discuss Trump's inauguration crowd can
you imagine if she went back to that
today Patrick Miller says I am a destiny
Stan but this gal is very attractive
okay
Townsend Koch says if you want a sense
of the 1918 plague I recommend the essay
influenza 1918 by Jane Brock's narrative
history very good I will check it out
and Kamala reichert says blowing Trump's
ego blowing Trump's ego I don't know
exactly what that means but I appreciate
the support
I also want to say thanks to Jill Weber
who is new member number three today at
join pakman.com how long do I expect
this briefing to go I don't know you
know with Trump sometimes the briefings
are two hours sometimes he won't take
any questions there's really no
regularity it seems to be dictated by
whether it's upper or downer Trump and
sort of time of day seems to some people
have thrown the term sundowning around
when it comes to Donald Trump I don't
know how long to expect Kelly McKenna
neat to be Caylee McKenna neat to be
briefing us today if I had to guess I am
going to say 42 minutes 42 minutes is I
mean what the I don't know anything I'm
gonna guess 42 minutes we will hear from
her today okay let's see here Alex Jones
says are you saying
because allegedly Trump assaulted 46
people it's okay for Biden to assault
women no I am not voting for a rapist
are you as far as I know Joe Biden has
not been found guilty of rape so I I
guess not and if he is he still would
have raped fewer people than Trump and
they one of the two of them is going to
be President I mean listen you know
there's a lot of people now who
starting to say stuff like hey you know
Biden should just quit cuz he's been
accused of sexual assault guys it's not
gonna happen he's just not going to quit
he's not going to quit it but you know
it either Trump or Biden are going to be
President unless one of them dies
between now and inauguration day and
Biden's better on just about every issue
I mean do I agree with what Bill Clinton
has been accused of when it comes to his
interactions with women of course not do
you I did one of the two of them is
going to be president and Biden is
better on at least 20 issues I can think
of off the top of my head you know do
whatever you want I'm not gonna argue
with you if this alex jones person wants
to vote for Trump go ahead dude not
gonna argue with anybody okay Pedro me
Ramon says unfortunately Trump won't be
held accountable for his actions but
let's remember that the fate is a cruel
that fate is a cruel mistress Danny
Thompson says save me Lord from lying
lips and from deceitful tongues Psalms
122 have a great weekend and thanks for
all you do thank you very much I
appreciate it
Austin Agyeman says ever been hypnotized
no do you think it's legit or just
placebo I don't know I think from what
I've learned if you want to be
hypnotized you it will happen and you
will believe you were hypnotized if you
don't want to or don't believe in it
from from what I've read it's very
difficult very difficult to hypnotize
someone who doesn't want to be Patrick
Miller says how do you tell if one is a
bad faith actor there's really no one
way I don't know that I'd be able to
tell you you know it that's a complex
issue that we should devote some more
time to someday a rich ropa thak says
Billerica is where Bill Clinton met his
favorite Erica I don't know anything
about that
and Maddie ice PVD says David Providence
is implementing slow streets to help
with social distancing on city sidewalks
certain streets will be closed to all
except EMS or pub a police department
interesting I didn't know that let me
also say thank you over on twitch Tzu to
side to side jumps Myer
- and susie-q and you thank you very
much appreciate that
oh people okay people are asking how
many members did we lose in April so I
do have the final numbers this I mean I
it pains me to say this as some of you
know our primary the way that our show
is mostly funded how we pay salaries
studio rent you know all this stuff is
people get memberships on my website
join pakman.com three people have done
it during this stream between March I
don't have the April numbers alone but
today I because it's May first between
March and April this is crazy 722 paid
members canceled their memberships 722
we've never had numbers like this before
you know Trump talks about unprecedented
things every day I can assure you what
is unprecedented is having 722 members
cancel in a two month period and we know
why it's because of the virus 20% of the
countries laid off another 30% has seen
ours cut or salaries reduced so I I get
it I get what's going on but if you are
in the boat of someone who can afford a
couple bucks a month I really would
appreciate you helping to balance out
the 722 people that canceled grab a
membership at join pakman.com it is
really really cheap the normal prices
are cheap but that coupon code right
there 2020 now will drop the price by an
additional 66% that makes it two bucks a
month if you pay for the year it's only
a dollar eighty a month so I really do
appreciate it
7:22 is rough for us 7:22 is that's
that's a lot I mean we're counting on
that revenue and I've made the
commitment that we're not cutting ours
we're not doing let we're maintaining I
think we can weather it I do but the way
that we've been weathering it is that
folks have been signing up so let me
thank a couple of those people right now
Trevor Godfrey has signed up at join
pakman.com and his new member number
four and Hannah Moore hey Hannah Hannah
has signed up at join pakman.com and is
new member number five thank you
I really do appreciate it it's you know
when I see these numbers when I when I
go you know I get notified via email
every time someone signs up and every
time somebody cancels in an ideal world
the sign ups are always more than the
cancellations when I wake up and we've
got five new members and twenty five
people that have canceled it's ugly it's
ugly but then we do the show and we move
on and we continue we continue what else
can I say all right other super chats
that are coming in here let's see here
satirical symphony says did they mention
at all this week that we hit a million
cases if they did I missed it another
reason for the distractions I don't
believe that trump has mentioned we now
have a million cases this week at all I
don't think so
let's see here M says thinks showing up
on time helps to garner respect I think
so if I work a Lima Kennedy I would show
up on time but of course I'm not and I
would not do Trump's interference forum
every single day Patrick Miller says
does existence precede essence I don't
know I don't know that is a very very
deep question that requires a lot of
analysis I couldn't tell you I'd have to
think about it let's see here Nessa
Wynne says I have Amazon Prime account
but I don't know how to subscribe with
twitch where do I go can somebody on
Twitch post a link in the chat for that
website where it tells you here's how
you link Amazon Prime to twitch to then
be able to get a free twitch Prime
subscription I know that there's a
website that tells you exactly how to do
it I just don't have it in front of me
and it would be great if somebody could
post that oli piece says how many
members did you gain to be transparent I
don't know the answer to that we've not
processed all of the April signups yet I
mean certainly in the hundreds but I
don't have final numbers on that Tiffany
Nicole says I joined specifically during
this time because I need facts thank you
for always being real I am a fan for
life Thank You Tiffany really appreciate
that
sincere coup has subscribed on YouTube
Roger says already a supporter but love
the work you do thanks for keeping me
sane and teaching me so much PS love the
economic content lately thank you
Charles Hess says already a member looks
like the market recovery has hit the
ceiling hope your portfolio is adjusting
yeah what's the what's the stock market
doing today Dow is down 600 ok yeah I
mean listen I've basically just conceded
that it could be 18 months until my
portfolio recovers interestingly because
of some of the purchases I made six
weeks ago that has sort of buoyed for
lack of a better term the portfolio a
little bit which is great which is
really really great ok let me say thank
you to a few other people who have
signed up Gary get here has made a
pledge on patreon I'm counting
everything guys if you want to pledge on
patreon instead of membership we're
counting it and Gary's number six Luis
Castillo or cast Isha as we would say in
Argentina my native land is new member
number seven today Taylor real is new
member number eight
Daniel Sherman is new member number nine
Rico Burkhart or reto Burkhart is new
member number ten today angel boa Divina
is new member number eleven
John Casella you are new member number
twelve Ben Gurevich is new member number
thirteen and patricia marcin Vaughn is
new member number fourteen today at join
pakman.com thanks to all of you very
much appreciate that
Patrick McDonough sends a super chat
well where'd that go there is favorites
says how worried are you if Trump wins
and he replaces Ruth Bader I'm super
worried extremely worried do you want
Trump getting to decide whether this how
the Supreme Court will decide cases that
could affect your children or
grandchildren no I certainly don't
I certainly don't I'm very worried about
that Austin Agyeman
says thoughts on Trump mobilizing these
aren't protests
to negate election results or for
another reason basically making his own
army of Twitter controlled Nazi
Brownshirts
uh listen I don't I don't know about
Nazi brown shirts but Trump is of course
partially responsible for fomenting
these protesters with tweets of liber8
Michigan liber8 Minnesota and that Trump
bears some responsibility not all but he
is certainly partially responsible
caller rycart says says I think all
Kayleigh will do is Trump post my best
my comment meant a verbal BJ for Trump
he's a narcissist and I'm more than
happy to tell us how great he thinks he
is got it
mistake not says just joined from
Scotland thank you
I actually have a couple of other folks
to thank wait a second okay Barbara
Parenti is new member number 15 and j
hovah neck is new member number 16 today
Steve and opal is new member number 17
thank Stephen Cindy Reap is new member
number 18 dennis nurse child is new
member number 19 and pamela goodman is
new member number 20 today thank you
very much I appreciate that also over on
Twitch most disgusting Virgil has
subscribed with prime and says thanks
for everything David we will get through
this together
I like that attitude also chili with
peppers
Scyther pre Susie Q and you have all
subscribed with twitch prime thank you
very much appreciate it if you're just
joining us we are ten minutes behind the
scheduled press briefing from Donald
Trump's new White House press secretary
Kelly McKenna nee this is her first
White House press briefing she this will
already put her ahead in terms of the
number of press but from the standpoint
of number of press briefings she'll be
ahead of trumps last press secretary
Stephanie Grisham who did zero press
briefings zero Kaley with one
will already surpass Stephanie Grisham
will be very interesting to see and we
are standing by I do want to see if
c-span has a stream because they tend to
always show the reporters asking
questions and it's just sort of like
better produced in my mind let me take a
quick look here I am not seeing a c-span
feed it's not clear c-span is taking
this oh wow one of the top streams is
this stream right now on YouTube very
very important make sure if you're
joining us on YouTube
you got to smash that like button you've
got to absolutely crush that subscribe
button that really does help get more
people more people in these streams okay
incredible TV says all you have to do to
search twitch in your Amazon app all you
have to do is search twitch in your
Amazon app or browser and click on the
link to my prime account took me seconds
love it love it those are the
instructions for using your Amazon
account to subscribe to me on Twitch I
love it ninja says these briefings are
reminiscent of a trypophobia catalog
take care of your country and vote you
cannot be neutral on a moving train
that's right there is no neutrality here
if you don't vote in November you're not
neutral you're not neutral Zachery
braille n'd oh here we go let's see what
we've got this is gonna be interesting
so good afternoon I have an announcement
for you on hospital funding as
appropriated in the third phase of
coronavirus relief propaganda the Trump
administration will distribute a total
of twelve billion dollars in provider
relief fund payments to 309 cool cross
across the country that have been
hardest hit by the Cova 19 pandemic
these hospitals have collectively cared
for over 70 percent of the 184 thousand
Americans that required hospital
inpatient care 10 billion of the 12
billion will go towards hospitals
treating 100 or more Kovan 19 admissions
HHS is distributing an additional two
billion dollars to these 395 hospitals
in proportion to the amounts of care
they put starting right away with
something that's really not news right
in the context of 2,000 people a day
dying 10 billion bucks and
reimbursements it's just not news so I
expected I'm taking this as a sign of
filibustering on of the states receiving
this funding and the county is receiving
this funding before your awareness New
York New Jersey and Illinois Illinois
received the most funding by States
while New York New York Bronx New York
and Cook Illinois received the most
funding by county as determined by our
metrics our healthcare providers as
president Trump has repeatedly
acknowledged are our heroes as we work
to defeat the invisible enemy
ok.this relief funding will help these
heroes defeat this virus and reacting to
Cara's relief I love what this one
provider said so he said thank you and
God thank you and God for this relief my
eyes out of gratitude for these funds
thank you so so so much right
additionaly 100 flights as part of
project air bridge have been completed
to date Penn State's planes had
expedited nearly 1 billion pieces of PPE
for our health care heroes the third
phase of coronavirus relief also
included 320 billion dollars in
additional funding for the paycheck
protection program which as you all know
provides forgivable loans to small
businesses in order to keep their
employees on payroll remember that the
money has run out for small businesses
and a lunch of huge businesses took
advantage is 1.6 million loans were
issued to small businesses of those 1.6
million loans 1 million of them were
given to companies with 10 or fewer
employees so it is gone to small
businesses
important to compare not number of loans
but number of dollars given to companies
of different sizes this is a very
deceptive way to present the data Ken's
who through no fault of their own have
found themselves in this predicament we
saw this firsthand at the White House on
Tuesday on Tuesday President Trump
welcomes small business owners and
employees to the White House these small
businesses received PPP loans which
helped them pay their employees during
the pandemic bit Ian Bose was among the
small businesses welcomed to the White
House this is actually Gish Gallup I
mean that there are probably already 12
inconsistencies that I can identify or
deceptions in what she said were three
minutes in did this is actually it's
impossible to actually keep up with it
peepee loans vidiian Bose was able to
rehire all of its employees am i had the
real honor of getting to meet Michael
Hoyt he's one of the employees at
bitties and bimbos and he offered some
words of encouragement to our country
and they really touched my heart and I
think they'll touch the heart of them of
America if you guys want mind playing oh
my god propaganda clips this this is the
this is the guy they used as a total
political prop that that disgusted me on
oh my god I can't now they're replaying
this might work I BMO's we like to use
the phrase called not broken that means
they should have taken this portion and
never played it again because it's such
transparent political props but instead
they're highlighting this clip this is
how mentally ill they are this is broken
either so I'm half of myself Megan and
Union all the employees that be involved
thank you
that they're actually even worse people
than I thought 20 minutes ago
Michael is an incredible young man I
gave him a call yesterday and asked him
what he was up to and he said he and his
fellow employees were literally
handwriting notes to put in with their
coffee packages that they send out to
consumerism I receive one of these notes
from another company and it really does
put a smile on your face and Michael's
doing that each and every day and
vidiian bows they represent the hope and
opportunity that is on the horizon for
America's workers as their body their
their business rather embodies the
American spirit workers like Michaels
show that this country is not broken and
that we will recover together Michael
thank you you're an American Hero
thank you for sharing that message of
hope and with that I'll take questions
welcome to the podium for the first time
thank you as well the markets are down
substantially today after the president
yesterday suggested in the East Room
that he might use tariffs to punish
China over the coronavirus is there any
serious consideration being given to
putting new tariffs on China could
someone actually mention that by the way
our companies pay the tariffs like
that's the thing to point out then but I
will echo the president's displeasure
with China it's no secret that China has
handled this situation just a few
examples for you they did not share the
genetic sequence until a professor in
Shanghai did so on his own the very next
day
China shut down his lab for quote
rectification they slow-walked
information on human to human
transmission alongside the World Health
Organization and didn't let us
investigators in at a very important
time so we take displeasure with China's
actions but I certainly won't get ahead
of the president's or her generic China
notes seriously considering forcing
China to pay some sort of compensation
reparations what whatever word you want
to put on it again when it comes to
retaliatory measures I will not get
ahead of the President on that
Thank You Kaylee and welcome to the
podium here as well the president said
yesterday that he has a high degree of
confidence that the corona virus
originated in a lab in mahón China and
yet his own intelligence agencies say
they're still investigating so does the
president have information and has he
drawn a conclusion that the intelligence
community has not yet well the
president's statement is consistent with
the other intelligence assessments while
we continue to have very limited and
dubious data from China current
assessments indicated that president
Trump's statement is consistent with
what some animal analysts believe is
really where the virus began and I would
note that intelligence the differences
she'll just stick to the notes where
it's Trump never would and he'll get his
foot in his mouth - that it began
through contact with infected animals or
was the result of an accident at a
laboratory in Wuhan so I consider that
consistent with what the president said
that he's seen intelligence suggesting
it could be in the Wuhan laboratory to
lean into the idea that this started in
a laboratory whereas the statement that
we saw from the DNI said we're still
investigating those two options that you
just laid out is the president in any
way of creating mixed messaging by not
saying no you know let me remind
everyone intelligence is just an
estimate essentially and it's up to
policy makers to decide what to do with
that intelligence this in this case the
policy makers the president of the
United States and he'll make that
decision at the right time because it's
me close to deciding what to do about
as he received any recommendations of
the consequences is he anywhere near a
decision
look again I won't get ahead of the
president's decision or the timing of
that decision but he takes this very
seriously because the decisions of China
that I referenced slow walking some of
that information put American lives at
risk and a rest assured this president
has one priority and that is the safety
and the well-being of American lives
Terry stood up there to get a better
sense of what your plan is are you
planning to do these in a daily basis at
this point and also will you pledge
never to lie to us from that I will
never lie to you you have my word on
those things on we do plan to do them I
will announce timing of that forthcoming
but we do plan to continue these welcome
to the to the podium question for you on
Project Work warp-speed can you give us
some more details on the president said
ultimately he's in charge of this
project but will there be a day-to-day
point person on this what's the budget
for this project and when can the
American people realistically expect
there will be a vaccine available well
there is a day-to-day point person and
that's the President of the United
States President Trump on that case with
regard to vaccines I would note some the
words of dr. Falchi which are these
going into a phase of one trial within
three months of getting the sequence is
unquestionable the world indoor record
nothing has ever gone this fast so what
the president is doing and under the
president's leadership we're in phase
one faster than ever before according to
dr. Falchi and that should encourage the
American people is budget in the budget
and then there's really no other point
person I mean I know the president
ultimately I guess the buck stops with
the president but he hasn't put somebody
on the on the staff
again our thought about putting a dog
breeder in place for a little while just
rest assured we're on an accelerated
pace to a vaccine at least for this
phase one portion of clinical trials
Thanks the the fed yesterday took an
action that appeared designed to allow
oil companies to access their lending
facilities so I'm wondering if the
president has spoken to chairman Cowell
about this
if he's happy about the move and if the
White House is considering any
additional assistance to the oil
companies so I won't get into the
president's personal discussions but I
would just note that the president is
always looking out for the nearly 11
million American workers in the oil
industry I would also note that we're
filling the Strategic Petroleum Reserve
right now and we'll buy 75 million
barrels so that's the only announcements
I have on the oil front today yes thank
you
the president tweeted this morning about
the protests in Michigan he essentially
said that the governor of Michigan
should work with the protests where she
called them very good people they are
very angry some of those process I'm
sure you saw included you know heavily
protesters members of militia groups I
wonder if the president was speaking
about those specific members who stormed
the capital and mio was referencing
generally that in this country you have
a First Amendment right to protest I
think that's something we all treasure
here and we should rightfully you have a
right to do that constitutionally but
you must protest within the bounds of
the law he encourages everyone to
protest lawfully and also to engage in
our social distancing guidelines which
we think all Americans should engage in
you have any response to this the
imagery of you know people with long
guns essentially storming the Capitol
going and to face off with police
officers and intimidating in some ways
the president says you know that we must
protest lawfully and act within the
bounds of the law yes thank you when the
president says we did a spectacular job
of when the giant Kushner's talks about
a great success story some Americans see
it as a lack of empathy what you
understand their reaction look you know
Jared Kushner has first of all done a
great job for this administration and
let me go to my Jared Kushner page in my
notes here he talked about a success
story he was talking about the story of
this administration which is a story of
mobilization for the American people the
greatest mobilization of American
industry since World War two of course
we grieve for every American life that
has been lost but we want the American
people to be confident in the response
of this administration and that is what
he was referring to the fact that in the
average year the health care industry
uses 25 million and 95 mass and we have
delivered in this short time 75 million
in 95 mass more than three times what
the health care sector uses in a year
that's extraordinary it's extraordinary
that you know some in the media were
saying that we needed a million
ventilators and this president has we
haven't we've needed far short of that
so far not not a single American has
died for lack of a ventilator and the
fact that this president I still don't
mean they're people in the eye and say I
am producing a hundred thousand
ventilators this year alongside the
private sector a hundred thousand
ventilators it's three times what we
produce in the average year I'd consider
that a great success on behalf of the
people it's more about the tone that the
policy itself we want to give the
American people confidence they have a
federal government that is doing
everything in our power to provide the
necessary equipment to convite it to
combat was not visible enemy we grieve
for the American lives we've said that
repeatedly I I will echo that today my
heart breaks for those I pray regularly
for those who are affected by water and
a virus but we're gonna get confidence
to the American people that you have a
federal government under President
Donald Trump that's going to step up and
give the greatest mobilization of the
private sector since World War two
thanks for being here president Trump
mentioned the situation in Brazil few
times this week
besides talks of cutting off flights
from Brazil are there talks of in terms
of sending assistance to Brazil sending
PPE or ventilators to Brazil and his
president Trump planning to talk with
president personally well the president
has mentioned that he has sent
ventilators around the world any excess
supply we certainly look to help other
countries but you know in terms of a
specific announcement regarding Brazil I
don't have any new information for you
on that front today welcome one of the
most important parts of your job though
is to have access to the president can
you give us some indication that since
you've been named press secretary what
kind of access do you have to the
president to get what he's thinking and
relay it to us yeah I can tell you this
I'm around the president almost the
entire day I was just with him before I
left to come out and speak with you guys
I think my staff can attest to the fact
that they have a very hard time finding
me because I'm normally with the
president and the Oval Office
so I'm consistently with him absorbing
his thinking and it's my mission to
bring you the mindset of the president
deliver those facts so this president
gets fair and accurate reporting and the
American people get fair and accurate
information right thanks Kaylee just
following up on Justin's question
China's blocking World Health
Organization from coming in and
investigating how this started shouldn't
external investigators be allowed into
Wuhan to determine one of
getting started and to maybe a way that
we could expedite finding a cure for
this thing look you know there's no
secret that China stopped us
investigators from coming in it was a
paramount importance that we got into
China in an expedited fashion and that
didn't happen with respect to the World
Health Organization they have some
questions of their own to answer the
United States says the president has
emphasized provides about 400 million to
500 million per year to the w-h-o
compared to China roughly 40 million a
year but yet the WHU still appears to
have a very clear China bias I mean you
look at this timeline and it's really
damning for the w-h-o and you consider
the fact that on December 31st you had
Taiwanese officials warning about human
to human transmission the w-h-o did not
make that public on january 9th the
whu-oh repeated China's claim that the
virus quote does not transmit readily
between people that was quite apparently
false On January 14th the w-h-o again
repeated China's talking points about no
human to human transmission at a praised
China's leadership on the 22nd of
January on the 23rd they said and this
is incredible the pandemic didn't
represent a public help them so here's
my take on the China thing I mean listen
there's no question that going after
China for withholding information being
a dishonest player all of that is
totally legitimate what we can't allow
is for Trump to claim that the situation
in the United States versus in any other
country entry had to deal with an
outbreak from a disease that started in
China as far as we know right now the US
is doing far worse than many countries
we are testing far less than many
countries our death rate is far higher
than in many countries
that's not uniquely because of China
relative to any other countries so it's
you know we want to be reasonable and
make sure that people aren't getting out
from under criticism by just saying well
this started in China okay it's its it
started in China for Italy as well the
president is resolute in saying that the
states take the lead here it's the the
lead the decision of governors to decide
what is best for their state that being
said you know I talked to the experts I
talked
dr. Burks I talked to dr. Falchi and
they say rightfully so this president
has always cited on the side of data is
why he encourages all follow the
data-driven guidelines to reopening all
states from Georgia on down the line
should follow those guidelines but
ultimately it is the decision of the
states and one note I would make about
the president in times of national
emergency we seem to have had a trend in
this country where presidents aggregate
power at the federal level but this
president has devolved power he's
invested in a principle that I cherished
I know many others do which is
federalism and I think that was really
because just ten days ago he was saying
he controls what every governor does I
have not spoken to him about Governor
Kemp in the last few days push this
forward should we open the country does
that mean he'll be campaigning in those
states where he that will be reopening
so I would refer you to the Trump
campaign on that question yeah yeah
thanks for being here can't wait um can
you mention dr. Fasching minute ago are
we gonna have any more press briefings
with dr. fector first health experts or
is the White House kind of shifting the
message to you know focus more on the
economy and less on the public health
aspect well let me back up and talk to
you a little bit about how we approach
disseminating information no just an
answer about whether we'll ever see
Falchi again is what we want I mean a
communication strategy for this White
House along with the president and Ben
as well you know what we do is we say
what is the best mode for the public to
receive this information at this time
and we allow the news cycle and the
needs of the American people to guide us
and you know at the moment what we see
happening and I hinted at this in my
goggle last week is yeah you have 35
states and probably more at this point
with plans to reopen the country
Americans are looking to reopening the
country we've had dr. Burks in several
events this week they've been dr. Brooks
and fouled she out on the airwaves
they're really incredible people and
I've done a great service for this
country but we allow the news of the day
to guide us what the American people
need to hear and right now we're in a
reopening phase which is why you've seen
the president this week with CEOs you've
seen him with small business owners who
thousand and people the day keep two
thousand people a day keep dying and
they're like no we're not really in the
phase where we need to be hearing from
doctors right now hard work so every day
we approach this as how can we
disseminate this information on
is a need for information which is why
I'm here supplementing that the efforts
of this president to get the message out
I would also note he's the most
accessible president in history took
questions twice yesterday twice the day
before you hear from him quite often as
well as well as their medical experts is
the taskforce still meeting I guess
what's the role of the provirus task
force we still have you know hundreds of
people a day are dying so what role that
was course I have versus the Economic
Advisory Group yeah the the taskforce
meets regularly I go to those meetings I
hear them we are dr. Burks I should say
is meticulously reviewing the data and
granular detail I watch them spend
sometimes the upwards of two hours in
these task force briefings so those are
those are still ongoing
rest assured we want a safe reopening so
we are prioritizing the help of the
American people as well as looking
forward to reopening this country
from yesterday there is a quote that I'd
like to forgive me your response to it
said the intelligence community also
concurs with the wide scientific
consensus that the coab in 19 virus was
not man-made or genetically modified
this was from the DNI statement how do
you see this stick how we understand
this then also there was the piece in
The New York Times that said senior
trump administration officials have
pushed intelligence agencies to hunt for
evidence to support the theory that Kobe
19 was made in a Wuhan laboratory I can
assure you that no one is pressing the
intelligence community to come to a
determination the intelligence community
statement stands it's in perfect concert
with what the president said so you know
I encourage the media to convey the
facts to the American people which is
that we're in line as an administration
and we stand by the intelligence
community and that is in complete
concert with the lift with what the
president said yesterday round two
that's great yes thank you today former
Vice President Joe Biden denied
allegations of sexual misconduct against
him does president talk take him at his
word given that as the press
said he has denied allegations against
himself well what I would say is that we
are pleased that the former vice
president has decided to go on the
record it took him less than what 16
hours to follow the advice of the
President of the United States and come
out and publicly address those claims so
you know we're glad to see that he's on
the record on this ask you about
something the president said moments ago
in an interview he said that Tara Reid
is quote far more compelling than
anything they had with respect to Brett
Kavanaugh what did he mean by that what
is more compelling that's the
president's assessment so I would point
you back to his words I think it was a
grave miscarriage of justice what happen
all I there's no need for me what would
happen if a reporter said will trump at
any point address the fact that a 13
year old said that Trump raped her
when would we expect the president to
comment on that meant for the Democrat
Party to have dragged the name of a very
respectable man through the mud like
that so I'll leave it at that there's
word the decision to release Michael
Cohen from prison to home confinement
due to Coba 19 has been reversed did the
White House directly or indirectly
intervene here no
so absolutely not I would say there but
I am glad that you brought up justice
and because again I've got a page
justice that is yet to be brought up
today but I certainly would like to
bring it up and that's the case of
General Michael Flynn coach should scare
every American citizen the fact that you
had Jim Comey
was a propaganda pivot the question was
about Michael Cohen protocol by
directing agents to confront Flynn
something that he would not quote have
gotten away with under previous
administrations the FBI told Flynn he
didn't need a lawyer when they came to
meet with him
McCabe told FBI agents that he didn't
think Flynn was lying and then all of
that information we've learned over the
last few months and years culminates in
the fact that we have a handwritten FBI
note that says quote we need to get
Flynn to lie quote and get him fired
that was there was an unfired unfair
target on the back of General Michael
Flynn imma to concern every
anytime there's a partisan pursuit of an
individual and that's certainly at least
those questions are raised with regard
to General Michael Flynn an honorable
man who served his country on that when
the president fired Michael Flynn he
said he was doing so because he had lied
to the vice president and he had lied to
the FBI so given all that you've just
said isn't it isn't it still truths and
the president still believe that Michael
Flynn lied to vice president Pence and
lied to the FBI well first let me
address that vice president Pence is on
the record about this he said he's
inclined to believe that Flynn did not
intentionally mislead him and I guess I
would turn the question on you and just
ask does it trouble you that the FBI
said we got to get Flynn to lie doesn't
that trouble you as a journalist and not
not only that it's certainly something
worth reporting it's not my job to say
whether or not it's troubling but yeah
what kind of a bottom line is the
president said point blank that Flynn
lied to the FBI it does the price no
longer think and I'm just asking a very
direct question does he still believe
that Michael Flynn lied to the FBI and
lied to the vice president and again I'd
point you to the vice president's
statement that he's inclined is what
Flynn did not intentionally mislead to
him what I'm asking back that all of you
and your coverage endeavor to report
what is a very scary story when the FBI
we're really important ones who lie I've
seen very scant coverage of that what is
the president's belief as of right now
Caylee people if you haven't heard it
yet are getting to here for the very
first time
going back to the South China Sea an
issue come up this morning where the USS
ferry crossing international Chinese
officials are saying that this will be a
dead end endeavour does has the
president spoken with what she's even
asking she forgets her question halfway
through what are your responses to
China's increasing aggression in the
South China Sea again I had no news to
report us to the president no
conversations and for the specifics of
that I would redirect you to the NSC
you're getting nothing thanks Oh in the
same pod cast interview the president
said the Democrats would quote have to
give us a lot for aid to States I'm
wondering if you have any idea of what
specifically the White House or the
president is asking for and secondly
what you'd say to somebody like Governor
Cuomo this says you know the president's
already told me that you know a few
weeks ago that he would support this
type of assistance and why are we
bailing out
you know Airlines or defense contractors
but not the states that plate that pay
teachers are first responders well first
you brought up Governor Cuomo so I just
thought it's a good time to remind
everyone that Governor Cuomo has praised
the president let me turn to hi any time
Cuomo is mentioned page
the president has achieved as a
phenomenal accomplishment and we thank
Governor Cuomo for those very kind words
but on that note with regard to funding
to States phase four is something that
we want to start negotiating good
negotiating on immediately and get to
work on the president has said look I
will certainly look to consider helping
States who have coronavirus reasons for
the financial situation they find
themselves
oh he's gonna consider helping states
decimated by crow right well this is
gonna consider it okay that have run
some of these states into a financial
predicament so he has mentioned that in
terms of the types of things he wants to
see in this phase for I don't want to
get ahead of the negotiations but I do
want to emphasize that he has mentioned
sanctuary cities this is a really
important issue that has cost American
lives on last year our brave ice
officers arrested more than 120,000
criminal aliens charged with nearly
10,000 burglaries 5,000 sexual assaults
45,000 violent assaults double murders
in the last year egregiously 5,000 human
trafficking episodes so American lives
matter our brave iseman and women matter
and it's something that he's mentioned
we'd like to see in a face for you
raised that and the president's been
kind of vague about this are you
explicitly conditioning
state aid on state cert or city is not
saying that they would have such versity
policies no I'm not no not conditioning
anything but saying that is a
negotiation item that the president will
certainly bring up thanks very much the
president has in the past deny any of
the allegations from the many women who
have accused do read actual misconduct
but for that podcast today you seem to
suggest the allegations that Tara Reid
has repeated star or whatever you say
credible than the ones against Brett
Kavanaugh um what about the allegations
that were raised against him however why
should the public or what makes them
them any less credible than the
allegations from Tara Reid the president
has swiftly denied all of these
allegations that were raised four years
ago he has always told the truth on
these issues
she denied them immediately and you're
bringing up issues like I said from four
years ago that were asked and answered
and the American people had their say in
the matter when they elected president
Trump as president of the United States
but you know the media leave it to the
media to really take an issue about the
former vice president and turn it on the
president and bring up accusations from
four years ago that were asked an answer
on the form of the vote of the American
people oh my god I just come back daily
to John's question because Kellyanne
Conway spoke to this the other day and
suggested that two things could be true
at the same time we have ice presidents
saying it's his belief that general
Flynn may have unintentionally
be selected that's now three years after
the fact but the two things that could
have been true at the same time was work
that Flynn lied to the vice president
and also lied to the FBI if you remove
the FBI piece of that what the president
still had fired Michael Flynn for is
he's not gonna have to get lied at that
point I mean I'm not gonna engage in a
hypothetical and I sensually what that
would be echo yet again that this was a
grave miscarriage of justice I am very
glad that the FBI thought to keep a
paper trail because what many have said
for a very long time pointing to the
first few facts I shared with you
culminating in that handwritten note I'm
glad they kept such good documentation
of their intent to slow-walk general
Flynn I'm into a trap and to essentially
create as I mentioned a grave
carriage of Justice so FBI at least we
can thank you for the great note-taking
does bring up the point that general
Flynn pleaded guilty to lying to the FBI
I'm not going to get involved in what
was a matter of your justice is it do
you not consider it a miscarriage of
justice it's not writing we want to get
someone to lie is that a miscarriage of
justice that's of course not with the
documents maybe and he pleaded guilty
though that's because this is an
adjudication of that dudes opinion
there's the media to cover it because
I've watched a lot of your networks I've
read a lot of your papers I've seen a
whole lot of scant information about
Michael Flynn when there was a whole lot
of speculation about Russia Russia
Russia culminating in 40 million dollars
of taxpayer money being lost in the
complete and total exonerees the whole
Russia thing actually made more money
and recovered assets than it cost but
she won't mention that see my little
five-month-old here in a few hours let
me just say this the president at 5:00
p.m. leaves today for Camp David it's
going to be working weekend he'll be
talking with heads of states a beautiful
week elected officials we have a great
event coming up this afternoon and of
course done everyone should watch the
Fox News Town Hall with the president
from 7:00 to 9:00 p.m. it'll be a
can't-miss television and much like the
highly rated president Trump coronavirus
Task Force briefings have been highly
rated she didn't even mention that that
Town Hall I believe is on Sunday might
be relevant to mention the day Wow Wow
incredible disinformation propaganda but
I mean listen maybe turning the
questions around on on journalists
there's a good strategy I don't know it
was very unusual but this is probably
what Trump likes to see I'm trying to if
I put on my trumpets hat and I see evil
Christian Barbie attacking the press you
probably think it's good right I mean
let me know in the chat what people
think
dozens of lies told but as a Trump I'm
putting myself in the mind of a trumpet
I think that they probably like it it
seems people in the chatter are agreeing
with me that the average Trump estaba
bleah see that pretty well yeah
interesting interesting and original
path acting himself attracted to
Kayleigh McKenna nice so there's that as
well coming in via super chat okay thank
you for joining me for this first of
who-knows-how-many Kayleigh McKenna knee
press briefings make sure to LIKE and
subscribe on the way out I may be back
for the Trump event in 90 minutes I may
not it depends on any number of factors
which I can't name but see you guys
either later today or after the weekend
you